The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right,
let's get started.
So welcome to another exciting
lecture about security
and why the world
is so terrible.
So today we're going to
talk about private browsing
modes, something
that a lot of you
probably have a lot of
personal experience with.
At a high level, what
is the goal of privacy?
When security researchers
talk about privacy,
what are they talking about?
Well at a high level,
they're talking
about the following goal.
So any particular user should be
indistinguishable from a bunch
of other users.
In particular, the
activity of a given user
should be non-incriminating
when viewed in light of activity
from a bunch of other
different users.
And so, as I
mentioned, today we're
going to talk about privacy
in the specific context
of private web browsing.
And so there's actually
no formal definition
for what private
web browsing means.
There's a couple different
reasons for that.
So one reason is
that web applications
are very, very complicated.
And they're adding new
features all the time
like audio and video
capabilities and things
like this.
As a result, there's
this moving target
in terms of what
browsers can do.
And as a result,
what information
they might be able to leak
about a particular user.
And so what ends up happening
is that in practice,
like with many things
involving browsers,
there's this living standard.
So different
browser vendors will
implement different features,
particularly with respect
to private browsing.
Other vendors will look and
see what vendor X is doing.
They will update
their own browser.
So it's like a moving target.
And as users grow to rely on
private browsing more and more,
they end up a lot of times
actually finding bugs
in private browsing mode,
as I'll discuss a couple
minutes later in the lecture.
And so private browsing
at a high level
you can think of as
an aspirational goal.
But we as society
are continually
refining what it means
to do private browsing
and getting better
in some aspects--
worse in some aspects-- as
we'll see a little bit later.
So what exactly do we
mean by private browsing?
It's tough.
But the paper tries to formalize
it in two specific ways.
So first of all, the paper
talks about a local attacker
on private web browsing.
This is someone who
is going to possess
your machine after you've
finished a private browsing
session.
And it wants to figure
out what sites you looked
at in private browsing mode.
And the paper also talks
about web attackers.
The web attacker is someone
who controls the websites
that you visit.
And this web attacker might
want to try to figure out
that you are some particular
person John or Jane as opposed
to some amorphous user
that the website can't
tell who they are.
And so we'll look at each one
of these attacks in detail.
But for now, suffice it to say
that if the attacker can launch
both of these attacks--
both a local and a web
attack-- that actually really
strengthens their ability
to try to dearm us.
So, for example,
a local attacker
who, for example, maybe
knows your IP address
can actually talk to the
website and say, hey,
have you seen this particular
IP address in your logs.
If so, aha!
You're looking at the user whose
machine I control right now.
So it's actually pretty useful
from a security perspective
to consider these
local and web attacks.
So they are separate
things and then to see
how they can possibly compose.
So let's look at this
first type of attacker,
which is the local attacker.
So as I mentioned, we
assume that this attacker
is going to control the
user's machine post-session.
And so by post-session, I
mean that the private browsing
activity has already finished--
the user has perhaps gone
off and done something else.
It's not at the computer.
And then the attacker
takes control of that issue
and wants to figure
out what's going on.
And so the security goal is
that well we don't the attacker
be able to figure out
any of the websites
that the user visited during
this private browsing activity.
Now, the reason why the
post is actually important
there is because if we assume
that the attacker can control
the machine before the
users private browsing,
then basically it's game over,
right, because the attacker can
install a keystroke logger-- the
attacker can subvert the binary
that [INAUDIBLE] the browser.
The attacker can subert the OS.
So we don't really care about
this pre-session attacker.
And also note that we're not
trying to provide privacy
for the user after the attacker
has controlled the machine.
And that's for the same reason.
Once the attacker
gets to the machine,
he or she can do the same thing
that is mentioned-- key logger.
So, basically, once the
user leaves the machine,
we don't assume any
forward notions of privacy.
Does that make sense?
It's pretty straightforward.
And so you can imagine that
another goal that you might
want to try to
satisfy here is you
might want to try to
hide from the attacker
that the user was employing
private browsing mode at all.
Now the paper actually
said that's very difficult.
This property is often
called plausible deniability.
So your boss comes up to you
after you use private browsing,
and says were you looking
at mylittlepony.com?
No, no, I certainly wasn't.
And I certainly wasn't
using private browsing mode
to hide the fact that I was
looking at mylittlepony.com.
So as I said, the
paper said it's
difficult to provide
this property
of plausible deniability.
I'll give you some
concrete reasons
why this might be the
case a little bit later
on in the lecture.
But that basically is an
overview of the local attacker.
So one question we might
want to think about
is what kinds of persistent
client-side state
can be leaked by a
private browsing session?
And by persistent,
I just mean stuff
that will end up getting
stored on the local hard disk,
the local SSD or whatever.
So what kinds of state might
be leaked if we weren't careful
when someone is doing this
type of private browsing?
So one thing you
might be worried about
is JavaScript accessible states.
So examplees of this includes
things like cookies and DOM
storage.
Another thing you might
be worried about--
and this is what most people
think about when they think
about what they want to
say in private browsing--
is maybe the browser cache.
So you don't want someone
to look in the inner cache
and figure out here
are some images or HTML
files from websites
you prefer people
didn't know that you visited.
Another important thing is
your history of visited sites.
So many of your
relationships have
been broken when the other goes
to the browser-- start typing
something into to the address
bar and all of a sudden
it auto-completes to
something very embarrassing.
So this is one
thing definitely you
don't want to leak outside
the private browsing session.
You can also think about
configuration states
with the browsing.
And so here you could
think about things
like client certificates.
You could also think about
stuff like bookmarks.
Maybe if you logged into a
particular site and the browser
offers to store your
passwords in another type
of configuration state that
you might not want leaking
from private browsing mode.
Downloaded files--
as we'll discuss,
this one's a little
bit interesting
because downloading a file
actually requires explicit user
action to download that file.
Maybe we do actually
want this stuff
to leak outside of
private browsing mode.
Maybe if you download something
in private browsing mode,
it should actually be accessible
when you open the browser
or use the machine
after that session.
So we'll talk about this
a little bit in a second.
And then, finally, during
private browsing mode,
you might install new
plug-ins or browser sessions.
That's another type
of state that you
might imagine you don't
want to leak outside
of private browsing mode.
So, basically, current
browsing modes typically
try to prevent one, two, and
three from leaking outside
of private browser sessions.
Right?
So there shouldn't be
any cookies or DOM stores
to get out of there.
Anything you put in a cache
during a private browsing
session should be deleted.
And you shouldn't have
any history of the URLs
that you're using.
Typically, four, five, and
six private browsing modes
allow to leak
outside of a session.
And there's some good
and some bad reasons
why this might be the case.
And as we'll
discuss later, we'll
see if you allow anything to
leak from the private browsing
session, that actually
radically increases the threat
surface of private leaks.
So it becomes much more
difficult to reason
about what the
security properties are
for private browsing mode.
Does that all make sense?
Anyone have any questions?
It's pretty straightforward.
So the next thing we're going
to talk about very briefly
is network activity during
private browsing mode.
And what's
interesting about this
is that even if we
cover all this stuff--
we don't allow private
browsing to leak anything
from there-- the mere fact that
you're issuing network packet
connections leave evidence
of what you were doing.
So imagine when you
want to go to foo.com,
the website, your
machine actually
has to issue a DNS resolution
request for foo.com.
So even if you don't
leave any of this type
of persistent state
up there, there
may be records in
your local DNS cache
that you, in fact, tried to
resolve the hostname foo.com.
That's very interesting.
So you can imagine
that browsers could
try to flush the
DNS cache somehow
after the private
session was over.
Now, in practice,
that's actually
tricky to do because
on many systems,
you require administrator
privileges to do that.
So it's not clear if you want
the browser running as root
because browsers, as
we've seen, are somewhat
untrustworthy individuals.
And also too-- a
lot of DNS flush
commands-- they don't
actually act per user.
They flush the
entire cache, which
is typically not what you would
want if you're implementing
private browsing mode.
You'd want to use a
type of surgical thing
where I only want to get rid
of foo.com and things that
were visited during this
private browsing sessions,
but not delete other things.
So in practice, that's kind
of a tricky thing to handle.
And another tricky
thing to handle,
which the paper mentions--
are these things
that I'll call RAM artifacts.
So the basic idea here is that
during private browsing mode,
that private browser has to be
keeping some stuff in memory.
And so even if the
private browsing mode
doesn't issue any direct
I/Os to disk-- user rights.
The RAM that belongs to
that private browsing tab
can still be reflected into
the page file, for example.
It can still be reflected
into the hibernation file,
for example, the laptop.
And so if that
state gets reflected
into persistent storage, then
what may end up happening
is that after your private
browsing session is over,
the attacker can look in
your page file, for example,
and find, for example,
JavaScript code that
was reflected to
disk or find HTML
that was reflected to disk.
So we're going to have a
little demonstration of how
this might work.
So if you see up
here on the screen,
I basically loaded up
private browsing tabs.
And so what I'm
going to do is I'm
going to go to some website.
So this is for the PDOS
group here at CSAIL.
I've loaded up that page.
And then what I'm
going to do is use
this fun command called gcore.
So, basically, I'm
going to take a memory
snapshot of this running page.
And so I will do
the following magic.
So basically there's
going to be some work
that my terminal is doing to
generate that memory snapshot.
So this takes a little
bit of time sometimes.
Now, what's happening here.
So now we've basically
generated the core file
for that private browsing image.
So what we're going
to do now is we're
going to look
inside of that image
and see if we can find
any mentions of PDOS.
And so what's
interesting is we see
a ton of instances of the
string PDOS in that memory image
for the private browsing mode.
And so what is interesting
is we actually see
various prefixes for things.
If we look further
up, we can see things
like there's full URLs
here and things like this.
You also find HTML
code in there.
So the point here is
that if we found all this
in the memory of that page, then
if this-- if any of those pages
got put to disk in the
page file, then he attacker
could basically
just run strings.
So they could do what I
just did over the page file
and try to find out what
sites that you visited
in private browsing mode.
So does that make sense?
Basically, the problem here
is that private browsing modes
don't try to obfuscate RAM
basically or encrypt it
in any way.
And that seems like a pretty
fundamental thing because
at a certain point,
the processor
has to execute on
clear text data.
And so this is actually
a pretty big challenge.
So does anyone
have any questions?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So one thing is
I don't expect my browser
to do that.
One thing is that these
browsers-- the guarantee
that they give you
through private browsing--
the example they give is if
you're shopping for something,
your layman friend
can't go on the computer
and see the things.
So can you talk a little bit
about what guarantees they give
and if they had
to change anything
as a consequence of this paper?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it's
very interesting.
One thing you can look
at is when you open up
a private browsing
tab, typically
there will be a little
blurb that says, hey,
welcome to incognito mode.
Here's where we'll
help you against.
We won't help you if someone
is standing behind you
with a rubber hose
about to beat you.
And so the browser
vendors themselves
area little bit cagey about
what guarantees they provide.
And in fact, after the Snowden
incident, a lot of the browsers
actually changed
that splash page
because they wanted to
actually make it clear
that we're not actually
protecting from strong ways
with the NSA or
something like that.
So long story short,
what guarantees
are they providing you?
In practice, they're
providing that weak thing
that you mention there.
It's like a lay
person who wanted
to see what you were
doing afterwards
couldn't figure out
what you were doing.
And we're assuming
the lay person
can't run strings on the page
file or things like that.
Now, the problem-- there's
actually two problems though.
One problem is that first
of all, because browsers
are so complicated,
they often don't even
protect against the layperson.
I can give you a
personal example.
So a lot of times when you
see those ridiculous ads
from "Huffington Post,"
like, oh, my gosh.
It's like puppies trying to
help small puppies go down
stairs and things like that.
Right?
Because I'm weak, I will
sometimes hook on those things.
But because I don't know
want people to know that,
I'll sometimes do that
in private browsing mode.
So what will happen sometimes
is that sometimes I'll
see those URLs will
leak into my URL history
like my regular, public
mode browser, which
is precisely what this
stuff is designed not to do.
So one problem is that
sometimes these browsers
don't provide protection
against the layperson attackers.
The second thing is I think
that there are actually
a lot of people who would
like for private browsing mode
to provide something
stronger, particularly
with the whole Snowden thing.
I think there is a lot
of people increasingly
who would like private
browsing mode to protect,
for example, against these
RAM artifact attacks,
even though they may not be
able to technically articulate
that goal.
And so actually one
of the things I've
done while I was
here, I got to do
some research in a stronger
private browsing mode
protection.
So we can chat about
that after all.
One of the things we
learn about all professors
is that we will talk about
our research endlessly.
So if you want to talk about
that for three hours just
send me a calendar request.
And we can do that.
So, anyway, this is
basically a demonstration.
Oh, you had a question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, about the RAM.
So I'm not familiar with
how it works exactly.
How come a browser can't
at the end of a session,
just ask the OS to flush those
parts around that he was using?
PROFESSOR: So we're
actually going
to get to that topic
in a couple of minutes.
But you are correct.
At a high level,
what you can imagine
is that maybe the OS when it,
for example, killed a process,
would actually go through
all those numbered pages
and write zeros to
all those pages.
Or you could also imagine
that maybe the browser tried
to pin all the pages in
memory to prevent anything
from getting flushed out at all.
So there are some
solutions that can do that.
So hold onto that
question for one second.
This is basically an
example of how data from RAM
can leak onto disk
through paging activity.
But note that data lifetime
is a bigger problem than just
in the context of
private browsing.
You can imagine that any
programs that deals with,
let's say, cryptographic
keys or user passwords
will have this problem.
Anytime you type in your
password to a a program,
the memory page which holds
that password can always get
reflected to disk.
So let me show you
another example of this.
So let's say that we looked at
the following program, which
is pretty simple.
It's called memclear.
So you see here at
the bottom and main,
we're just going to read in
some secret text file here.
And then we're just
going to sleep forever.
So what is that Read Secret do?
Basically, it reasons from file.
It's going to print out
the contents of that file.
And then it's actually
going to clear out
the buffer that was used to
store that secret information.
So getting back to your issue.
So one can imagine the
browser, for example,
would try to just memset to
zero all the secrets that it
encountered when it's
just in private browser.
So if we look at the secret
files, it's not very fun.
It just says, my
secrets of in a file.
And then if we run this
program, in the background--
so what did it do?
So like I said, it
just printed it out.
It read that file in, printed
out the secret value--
cleared the memory
buffer that it
used to print that stuff out.
Now it's just sleeping
in the background.
So once again, if we use
this fun gcore command,
we can take a memory dump
of the memclear program
that's running in
memory right now.
OK, and then if we
do-- let's see which
ones we're going to look at.
So then if we look at--
this guy is the one we want.
And then we do a
grep for a secret.
So once again, we
see that if look
in the RAM image of
that running program,
we found instances of
both the file name that
was read in and also some
prefixes of the string
contents of that
file, even though we
wiped the buffer in
the C program itself.
So you might say
why did this happen?
This seems very, very strange.
And the reason is that if
you think about the way
that I/O works, it's
like a layer type thing.
So by the time that the
contents of that file
get to the program, it's
already gone through, let's say,
the kernel memory.
It's already gone through maybe
like the C Standard Library
to do I/O because
that library does
buffering and stuff like that.
And so what ends up
happening is that even
if you memset the
application visible buffer,
there are still instances
of secret data lying
in many different places
throughout the system.
And this is looking
at the user mode
portion of this application.
So there's probably still
data sitting around in maybe
like the kernel I/O buffers
or things like that.
So getting back
to your question,
if you want to do what they
call security allocation,
you can't just rely on
mechanisms at the application
level because there may be other
places where that data lives.
So what are some
examples of other places
where this data might live?
So, for example, it might
live in a process memory.
So these are things like
the heap and the stack.
So when we did that memset
inside of memclear.c,
we were basically
trying to address this.
But what we found
out is that that
is necessary, but insufficient
to actually clear all instances
of that secret from memory.
So where else my RAM
artifacts live or secret data
persists-- so all
kinds of files--
backups-- SQL write databases.
If at any point, an application
takes something in RAM
and writes it to one of these
things, then once again,
the attacker may be able to
recover that after the attacker
controls the disk .
As I mentioned, a kernel
memory is another common place
where RAM secrets may
live because, once
again, applications typically
do layered I/O in which
each piece of data goes through
multiple parts of the stack.
Think of like network
transmission, for example.
First, the data has to come
to some network buffer that's
probably inside the kernel.
Then once again, it probably
goes through some buffers
inside the C Standard Library.
And then finally it will
go to the user mode--
the part of the application
that the developer wrote
him or herself.
So that can actually
be a big problem.
You can also think too of
freed memory pages as being
a place where data can leak.
So imagine that your
application allocates
a bunch of memory using
whatever [INAUDIBLE] or whatnot.
And then that process dies.
And the kernel sends
out another process
but hasn't actually zeroed
out all the physical RAM page.
So what could happen is that
when that new process spins up,
it could just do a walk through
all this physical RAM pages
and use a bunch of
memory and just do
the same thing-- do the
strange thing-- see if there's
anything interesting there.
And then they might be able
to get secrets that way.
So there's a lot
of ways information
is leaked from the kernel.
You could also think about
I/O buffers and things
like a keyboard from
things like the mouse.
There's just a bunch
of different factors
that data can leak
through the kernel.
How might an attacker try to
get some of this information?
Well, in some
cases, it's just as
simple as reading the files--
so just read the page file.
Read the hibernation file
and just see what's in there.
Some file formats actually
embed different versions
within themselves.
For example, the way that
Microsoft Word used to work
is that a single Word file
would actually contain versions
for old pieces of data.
So if you could get
access to that Word file,
you could just sit there
through either format
and so step through
all the old versions.
And so as we have been
discussing in the last couple
minutes, security allocation
is also a problem.
It cannot supported
a full stack.
So for example, an older
Linux kernel-- when
you would create a
directory, end directory,
you could leak up to four
kilobytes of kernel memory.
Only Zeus knows what's
inside that memory.
And that's because Linux
wasn't actually zeroing out
kernel memory that had been
allocated, deallocated,
and then allocated
to something else.
So as I mentioned before too--
if the kernel doesn't zero out
pages that are given
to user mode processes,
you can also have
user mode secret
leaks through those types
of menu pages as well.
Another thing is that-- SSDs--
many of them implement logging.
And so in other words, when
you send a write to an SSD,
oftentimes you are not
directly overwriting data,
you're actually
writing to a log.
And when a piece of
data becomes invalid,
it lays away your claim.
So what that means is that if
you as the user get unlucky.
And you've written a bunch of
data that hasn't been reclaimed
by the SSD, then
maybe the attacker
can look at that
hardware and say, oh, OK,
I understand the log format.
And even though
technically speaking,
this data may be
invalid, I can still
recover because I understand
how the Flash translation layer
works or something like that.
And at a high
level, you can also
have this problem with stolen
or discarded hardware as well.
If you don't use encryption,
then a lot of times,
you can just take
some disk that you
found in a dumpster
somewhere-- you
understand what the
physical layout is
and recover data like that.
So anyway, there's
a lot of problems
with these RAM artifacts getting
stuck in persistent storage
somehow and then being available
for an attacker later on.
So how can we fix these
data lifetime problems?
So we've already
discussed one solution,
which is to basically
zero out memory
when you're done with it.
So whenever you deallocate
something, you just go through.
You write a bunch of
zeros or some random thing
and then essentially
hide the old data
from someone else who
might come along later.
So does anyone see potential
any potential problem with that?
One problem you might imagine
is that as with all things
in security, people always
complain about performance.
And so when you say that
you zero out memory,
maybe this isn't a problem
if your program is I/O bound.
So you're waiting on some
slow, mechanical part
of the hard disk or whatnot.
But imagine if your
program is CPU bound.
And maybe it's very
memory intensive too.
So it's always allocating
and deallocating data.
So maybe zeroing out memory
might be performance cost
that you don't want to pay.
Typically this isn't
a problem in practice.
But as we all know,
people love performance.
This is sometimes an
objection that you'll
have with this approach.
Another thing you
can imagine doing
is that instead of
zeroing out memory,
you always encrypt data as
it goes to stable storage.
So in a system like
this, basically,
before the application ever
writes anything to disk,
it's actually going to encrypt
it before it actually hits
that SSD or that hard disk.
Similarly, when the data comes
back in from stable storage,
you're going to
decrypt it dynamically
before you put it into RAM.
And so what's interesting
about this approach is
that if the key that you use
to decrypt and encrypt data--
if you throw it away, then
once you throw it away,
you've effectively
made that data on disk
unrecoverable by the
attacker, assuming that you
believe in cryptography.
So this is very, very
nice because it gives us
this nice property
that we don't have
to remember per se all
places where you've
written this encrypted data.
We can just say
why drop the keys?
And I'll just treat
all that encrypted data
as it's something that
I can allocate again.
So, for example, if
you look at Open BSD,
they have this option where
you can do swap encryption.
So you can basically
associate keys
with various sections
of the page file.
So it does this very
thing I mentioned.
So every time you
group the machine,
it'll generate a
bunch of new keys.
And then when your machine goes
down because you shut it down
or you reboot it or
whatever, it will basically
forget all the keys that it
used to encrypt that swap space.
And then it can basically
say now all that swap
is available to be used again.
And so because those
keys are forgotten,
one can assume that
the attacker can't look
at the stuff that is in there.
AUDIENCE: What is
the [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Ah, yeah,
that's a good question.
I'm actually not sure what
sources of entropy it uses.
Open BSD is pretty
paranoid about security.
So I imagine it
does things like it
looks at let's say the
entropy pool gathered
from user keyboard
input, for example,
and other things like that.
Yeah, I'm not actually sure
how it drives those keys.
But you're exactly right that
if these sources of entropy
that it uses are predictable,
then that basically
shrinks the entropy
space of the key itself,
which then makes the
key more vulnerable.
AUDIENCE: So with the memory
it's capturing [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so basically,
what this model assumes
if all we are doing is looking
at the swap encryption,
It assumes that the
RAM pages for the keys,
for example, are
never swapped out.
And that's actually
pretty easy to do
if you're the OS of if you
just pin that page to memory.
And this also doesn't
help you with someone
whose got pins with the
memory bus or someone who
can walk the kernel memory
page or stuff like that.
So you're right.
AUDIENCE: In terms
of browsing, it
helps of attackers that
come after the fact
because if you have
to throw away the key,
then after the fact,
there is no key to memory.
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
that's exactly right.
So what's nice about this
is that it essentially
doesn't require modifications
to applications.
Like you said, you can just
put any old thing atop this
and get this property for free.
AUDIENCE: Going back a bit--
if you look at the data
before [INAUDIBLE] to RAM.
How does that avoid the
RAM artifacts [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: OK, so if I
understand your question
correctly, I think you're
worried about the fact
that, sure, data is
encrypted when it's on disk,
but then it actually can
sit in clear text forms
somehow in the
actual memory itself.
So this gets back to the
discussion that we had here.
So ensuring that data
hit the disk encrypted
doesn't actually protect
against an attacker who
can look at RAM in real time.
So basically what
we're saying is
that if you're only worried
about this post-session
attacker who can't, for
example, look at your RAM views
in real time, this works fine.
But you're exactly right
that this does not provide,
for lack of a better
term, encrypted RAM.
And there actually are
some research systems that
try to do something like that.
It gets a little bit tricky
because at some point when
you look at your
hardware, your processor,
it has to actually do
something on real data
like if you want to do an ad and
you have to pass a clear text
operands perhaps.
There are also some
interesting research systems
which actually try to do
computation on encrypted data.
This is mind blowing
like "The Matrix."
But suffice it to say that
protections that people have
for in RAM data are typically
much weaker than what
they have for data that
lives on stable storage.
You got a question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, but
does that [INAUDIBLE]
because even though the attacker
has post-session access,
that's just post-private
mode access.
So there could
this could still be
a public mode session going on.
And the attacker would have
access to the machine, right?
PROFESSOR: So you're worried
about if a concurrent--
AUDIENCE: So if you
have a public mode tab
and you have a private mode tab.
You close the private tab
and the public mode tab
stays on-- the attacker
could still dump the memory.
And the RAM artifacts
would be problematic.
Is that right?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
interesting-- so we
will talk at the end of
lecture about an attack which
is somewhat similar.
So most of the threat
models of private browsing
due not assume a
current attacker at all.
In other words, they
assume that when
you're doing private
browsing, there
is no other person
who have a public mode
tab open or anything like that.
But you are in fact correct that
the way that private browsing
modes are often
implemented-- let's
say you open up a
private browsing
tab, you close that tab.
You immediately run to
go get a cup of coffee.
So one attack I will describe
is that Firefox, for example,
still keeps statistics about,
let's say, memory allocation.
So if the memory
for your private tab
is actually laid
with the garbage
collected and I can basically
go to about.memory or whatever
and actually see URLs
and stuff in your tab.
But yeah, but the long story
short, most of these attacker
models do not assume
a concurrent attacker
at the same time that
you're privately browsing.
Make sense?
So this is one that you
do-- do swap encryption
like I mentioned.
This is nice because this gives
you some pretty cool security
properties without
having to change
the browser at all or
any of applications
running on top of this.
And in practice, the CPU cost
of doing this kind of thing
is much, much lower
than the actual cost
of doing I/O in
general, particularly
if you have a disk
because with disk you're
particularly paying C cost.
That's a mechanical cost.
This is all processing cost--
pure computational stuff.
So typically this not that
big of a performance hit.
Oh, god there's physics here.
This is always an adventure.
So the next attacker that
we're going to look at
is this web attacker
that I mentioned
at the beginning of lecture.
So the assumption here
are that the attacker
who controls the website
that the user is going
to visit in private
browsing mode--
how the attacker does
not control the user's
local machine.
And so the security
goals that we
want to have against the
web attackers are two fold.
So first, we don't
want the attacker
to be able to
identify the users.
And by identify
with, we just mean
we don't want the attacker
to be able to distinguish
the user from any
other user that happens
to be visiting the site.
And you also might
imagine that perhaps we
don't want the attacker to
tell whether or not we're
using private browsing mode.
So the attacker can't
tell the user employees
private browsing.
And so as the paper
discusses, defending
against the web attacker
is actually pretty tricky.
So what does it
mean, for example,
to identify different users.
Like I said, at a high
level, as you could imagine,
the user looks no different
than any other users
that visits this site.
So you can imagine
a web attacker
might want to do one
of two specific things.
It might want to say, OK,
I see multiple people who
were visiting my site in
private browsing mode.
You were visitor five,
seven, and eight.
So in other words,
identifying a particular user
within the context of multiple
private browsing sessions.
The second the attacker
might want to do
is actually try to link a user
across public and private mode
browsing sessions.
So I go to Amazon.com once
in public browsing mode.
I then go to it again in
private browsing mode.
Can the attacker
actually figure out
that I'm actually
the same person
through those two visits.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: This is all a
module of the IP address.
PROFESSOR: Ah, yes,
that's exactly right.
That is excellent foreshadowing.
So right now I'm assuming that
either user employs Tor or uses
something like this.
So yeah, we're punting
on this whole issue of IP
admittedly for now.
That's right.
So yeah, this segues very well.
So what's an easy way
to identify the user,
as you suggested,
the IP address.
So it's a pretty high
likelihood if you
see two visits that are
sort of close in time
relatively speaking
with the same IP
with high likelihood that's
probably the same user.
And this in fact
the motivation-- one
of the motivations
for stuff like Tor.
And so we're actually willing
to discuss Tor next lecture.
So in case you
haven't heard of Tor,
it's basically a tool which
tries to obscure things
like your IP address.
And you could actually
imagine layering Tor--
having Tor be the foundation.
And then you put private
browsing modes atop that.
And that might give you some
stronger properties then
you would if you used private
browsing modes at all.
But, anyway, so the thing
to mention about Tor
though is that Tor does provide
some sense of IP anonymity.
But it doesn't actually address
things like the data secrecy
lifetime issues or
things like that.
So Tor-- perhaps you can think
of it as maybe necessary,
but insufficient for
a full implementation
of private browsing mode.
And so what's interesting
too is that even if a user
employees Tor, there are still
ways that a web server can
identify the user by looking
at the unique characteristics
of that user's browser.
So this is our final
demo for today.
So let's see here.
So going to get rid of this guy.
And then let's see.
I am going to go to this
site called Panopticlick.
Some of so you heard of this.
It's run the EFF.
The basic idea is it is going
to try to identify you the user
by looking at various
characteristics of your web
browser.
So I'll show you
exactly what I mean.
So I want to go--
the URL is very long.
This is very stressful
for me to type in.
So please don't just if
it doesn't go through.
Let's see.
Panopticlick-- did it work?
Yes, OK.
So I am going to
go to this website.
And it's run by
the folks at EFF.
And I say, OK, test me.
So what this is doing
is it's basically
running a bunch of
JavaScript code, maybe
an applet-- maybe some Java.
And it's trying to
fingerprint my browser.
And it's trying to figure out
how much unique information
does it have.
And so-- let me
increase the font here.
So, for example, one
thing it looks at
is it looks at you
see here what are
all the details of the browser
plugins that I'm running.
So basically it'll run
code in it's web page
that looks and sees do
I have Flash installed?
What version of Flash?
Do I have Java installed?
What version of Java?
So you can see that these
are all-- they can't even
fit on the tree at one time.
These are like all the various
plugins and ridiculous formats
that my browser supports.
Now, the high level-- this
should be troubling to you
if you're a security person.
Am I actually actively
using all of these things
at a given time?
This gives me nightmares.
So what ends up
happening is that web
servers-- this web attacker--
they can hunt code like this.
And they can figure out what
are all the plugins that you're
looking at.
Now if you look at these
two columns to the left,
what are they?
So you see up here.
It says bits of
identifying information.
And then one in x
browsers has this value.
So, for example, if
we look at a plugin,
it's saying there is
basically-- it's probably
this is the number
that's more interesting.
It's no longer right.
It's saying that 1 in
approximately 280,000 browsers
has this exact set of plugins.
So that's actually a pretty
specific way to fingerprint me.
It's saying very,
very few people
who have this exact set of
plugins and configurations.
So as it turns
out, they're right.
I am quite unique.
But this a problem from
the security perspective.
So look at this.
The screen size and the
color depths for my machine--
1 in-- what is this?
1.5 million.
That's actually pretty shocking.
So there's only one person in
a sample of 1.5 million people
who have this
particular screen image.
So these things-- they are
additive in some sense.
So the more fingerprints
you have, the more easy
it is for the attacker to
figure out exactly who you are.
And so note this was done
purely from the server side.
I just went to this web page.
And I just did this.
And this is what it got to.
One second-- I want to
show one more thing.
This was done in
private browsing mode.
And let's see here.
I will open up a regular
version of Firefox.
Then I run this up again.
So note that now I'm in
a public mode browser.
Before I was in private mode.
Now I am public mode.
So what you'll see is that when
we look at the browser plugins,
the extent to which I
can be fingerprinted
is essentially the same.
So it's going to be a few
plugins that may or may not
load depending on
the vagaries of how
privacy mode is implemented.
But still, look at that.
I'm still very easy
to fingerprint.
And in fact, if you
look back at this guy
again-- that screen
size and color depth.
I didn't change that
actually between the two--
between public and
private browsing mode.
So that ability to fingerprint
there is basically the same.
This is one reason why it's so
difficult to protect yourself
against this web attack because
browsers themselves reveal
so much information about you
just from their configuration.
AUDIENCE: I am curious the
screen size and color depth
thing.
How does it do that?
How is that unique?
How many screen sizes and
color depths are there?
PROFESSOR: Well, I
think it's actually
hiding some of the
magic that it's using
to figure out what that is.
So at a high level, how do
a lot of these tests work?
So there's some parts of
your browser environment
that are testable purely
by JavaScript code.
So you can imagine that
you can essentially
have JavaScript
code, which looks
over the properties of
the window object, which
is like a global
JavaScript manuscript
and sees how do you
define this weird widget?
How do you define
this weird widget?
And if so, that my count
your plug-ins, lets say.
Pages like this also typically
take advantage of the fact
that Java applets
and Flash objects
can look at all kinds of
more interesting stuff
like the fonts that are
available on your machine
and things like that.
So as to the particular screen
size and color depth thing--
I think-- don't
quote me on that.
But I think what
ends up happening
is it will try to run an applet,
let's say, that will actually
try to query your graphics card
or whatever are the graphics
interfaces in Java and poke
for different aspects of it.
So I think it's actually
more than just screen
size and depth.
They condense it
for size as that.
So at a high level, that's
how all these tricks work.
So you see a bunch
of information--
you can snarf up
through JavaScript.
Then you run a bunch
of plugins, which
can typically access more stuff
and see what they can snarf up.
And then you see
what's going on.
Does it all make sense?
Yeah, this is basically why
it's very difficult to protect
against a web attacker.
And in particular, getting
back to the discussion we
had about Tor, right, even if
I had gone through Tor-- so
you'll note the IP address--
you don't see it up here.
And so you can
imagine that yeah,
maybe this thing would actually
look at your IP address.
But the thing is
like even if I didn't
know what IP you were
coming from at all,
I can do all these things.
It's pretty maddening.
It's pretty insane.
So there are some
products out there
that tried to do
things like imagine
that you had a proxy
out in the cloud
that all your web
traffic went through.
And then imagine
that proxy tried
to present a canonical
version of a browser runtime.
And imagine that it would
always try to emulate,
let's say, Firefox v 10.7.
Then it would try to
send back the data
that it rendered
as Firefox v 10.7.
So some people would
try to attack this.
It's sort of tricky.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: I am not--
AUDIENCE: Is that
Tor distributions?
Is that paired with
virtual machines?
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: I see--
so the basic idea--
is it a similar idea to what
we were just talking about?
AUDIENCE: Yes, [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so I
never heard of that one.
I have heard of some of
these other projects.
I'm imagining there's actually
some trickiness in getting
systems like this to be
efficient a lot of times
because particularly imagine
if you have something that's
interactive.
It's like you want to play a
game or something like that.
It's a little bit
awkward to send my mouse
click to some proxy.
That proxy is then somehow
going to [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Let me clarify the
first station virtual machine
actually runs
[INAUDIBLE] Firefox.
In the proxy it's
known as a Tor.
PROFESSOR: Ah, it's
just a Tor proxy.
So if it's a Tor proxy,
sure, that's one thing.
Then the only overhead
there you have to pay
is the regular Tor
overhead of going
through all the onion route.
Yeah, so I was talking
there are systems--
let's ignore the IP
anonymity for a second
because they
basically try to say
you have your own very
fingerprintable browser
on your own machine.
You don't want to expose
that to the web server.
So essentially you
go through a proxy,
which you think
of it all the time
like a headless Firefox let's
say of some canonical version.
The web server thinks it is
interacting with this thing.
So if I go load this site, I
am perceived by the web server
as Firefox 10.7 or whatever.
If you go there, you are also
perceived as Firefox 10.7.
Then behind the scenes its'
spitting out HTML and stuff
like that it collected
from the proxy.
So those two things
are orthogonal.
AUDIENCE: But it seems like you
don't need a proxy for this.
You could have browser
support for this, right?
Meaning the Tor
browser does this
already by trying to appear
as the most generic version
of Firefox.
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
so this is true.
Although, I think a problem
with a lot of those things
that even if you try to lock
yourself into one version,
there's still a lot of things
that can fingerprint it.
So I think with the Tor
distribution, what they often
do is they say, we control
what's in the Tor distribution.
So if we all go down to the Tor
distribution, then forshizzle,
we're both going to get Firefox
with the same Java version--
the same so on and so forth.
AUDIENCE: Well, it's
more than that though.
They return screen sizes that
are the most common screen
sizes whenever you
clear the screen.
PROFESSOR: That's all true.
Yeah, so one thing that's
interesting to look
at though-- the Tor team that
also put out-- the people who
do the bundle-- they'll often
put out reports about what data
still gets leaked.
So stuff does still
get leaked out.
But you're right.
If you could-- the high level
of that goal is very reasonable.
It's saying that
if we all agreed
to download the
same distribution
and to then not trick it out by
adding plugins or stuff like,
then you're exactly right.
That'd work great.
Any other questions?
Yeah, so that is
it for demo time.
And there's more physics.
This must have been a
riveting previous class.
So we will ignore
that for the moment.
Let's see here.
So where were we?
So what is the high-level
goal of privacy?
And you can think
of it as what's
your anonymity set
if you're a user?
So in other words,
how many-- what's
the size of people--
the number of people
that you could be
confused for-- you
could be mistaken
for by an attacker.
And so what the browser
fingerprinting stuff shows
is that oftentimes a web
attacker can narrow you
down to a very, very
tight demographic
without controlling anything on
your local machine whatsoever.
So that's actually little
bit frightening to know.
So you might want
to think about how
can a web attacker determine if
you're using private browsing
mode?
Maybe that's [INAUDIBLE]
for some reason.
So in the paper they
actually describe an attack
that uses link colors.
So remember, in
private browsing mode,
the browsers isn't
supposed to keep
track of the history of
the sites that you visit.
And so in the paper, the
authors describe an attack
in which essentially the
attacker-controlled page
creates an iframe to some URL
that the attacker controls
and loads that inside
the attacker page.
And then it basically
looks at the link colors.
It creates a link
to that page-- that
iframe it just
created-- and then sees
that the link color for that
link is the visited color.
So see it as purple versus blue.
And the idea that if you do this
test in private browsing mode,
then presumably the
link colors should
stay like the unvisited
color because the browser
is supposed to be forgetting
about all this kinds of stuff.
So that's the attack they
describe in the paper.
What's interesting is
that this attack actually
doesn't work anymore.
So we actually discussed this
a couple of lectures back.
So this attack that
the paper describes
is the browser history
sniffing attack.
So as we discussed a
couple of lectures ago,
JavaScript code now does not
expose correct link colors
basically to JavaScript .
And it's precisely to prevent
these types of attacks.
So that particular part
of the paper is outdated.
AUDIENCE: What does it point
to that browsers now also show
links as purple in
private browsing mode
and turn blue again
when you exit.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it's
a bit weird, yeah.
They implemented that
attack-- the defense--
I think before a lot
of the private browsers
like a popware.
So now they do this
additional thing too.
The long story short, the attack
they describe in the paper
doesn't work because of some
of these browsers sniffing
defenses.
But you can still
imagine that there
may be ways for the web attacker
to figure out if you are
using private browsing mode.
So for example, when you
do private browsing mode,
any cookies that you
got from public mode
should not be sent
during private mode.
So in other words, if I go
to Amazon.com in public mode,
I generate some cookies.
Then I go to Amazon.com
in private browsing mode.
When I contact Amazon.com
in private mode,
those public mode cookies
should not be sent.
That can actually act as
the sign to the web attacker
that you actually are
using private mode.
AUDIENCE: This is also now
you're using the canvass
in both of these events, right?
So you need to know
the IP address.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that's right.
AUDIENCE: So that
link that you were
targeting with the link color
would be on a per IP basis.
And you would have to
rely that the user first
visited it as a public
mode, and you protect it.
PROFESSOR: Ah, so the
link-- so the link
attack you can actually do in
the context of a single page.
So imagine that I,
the web attacker,
construct single page.
I, the attacker, have JavaScript
that creates an iframe
to foo.com like this.
So that iframe will load
the contents of that page.
And then I, the attacker,
in the parent frame
can then create a
link element and then
try to look at the color.
This worked four years ago.
So in that case, it doesn't rely
on the user having explicitly
visited that iframe page at
all because I, the attacker,
can create that in the
context of the page.
I have gotten [INAUDIBLE].
Any other questions?
So yeah, so you can maybe
think about how cookies
can reveal public and
private browsing modes
and things like that.
So one thing we
might think about
is how we can provide
a stronger privacy
guarantee for private browsers?
And for the sake
of this discussion,
let's just ignore
IP addresses for now
because as we'll
discuss next lecture,
we can used Tor to
maybe help with some
of the privacy of IP addresses.
So one thing you
can imagine doing
is you can imagine
using VMs in some way
to help provide stronger private
browsing guaranteed-- so VM
level privacy.
And so the basic
idea is that you
want to run each private
session inside of a separate VM.
And then when the user
is done with that--
so is finished with the
private browsing session,
you basically delete VM
after that session is done.
So what's the advantage of this?
Well, what's nice about
this is presumably
you can get some
stronger guarantees
about what privacy properties
you can provide to the user
because, presumably,
the VM has a pretty
clean interface to the I/O
path of the underlying post-OS.
So you can imagine
that maybe you
combine this VMs into let's
say some type of a secure swap
solution like Open BSD has--
give us another encrypted disk
type thing.
So you can imagine, OK, we have
a very clean separation of VM
up here and all the I/Os
that are generated down here.
And so that gives you
stronger guarantees
than what you can get from the
browser, which wasn't designed
from the ground up to think
very carefully about all the I/O
paths and what secrets might
leak when it was in storage.
So yes, this
provides what's nice
about this-- strong guarantees.
And, also, what's nice
is it doesn't require
any changes to your
applications-- that
is to say to the browser.
You take your browser,
put it inside one
of these VMs-- then everything
gets better all magically.
It's not location change.
So what's bad about this--
I'll use an unhappy face
to demonstrate that.
So what's bad is first
of all, it's heavyweight.
And by heavyweight,
I mean that time you
want to spin up one of these
private browsing sessions,
you have to spin up a whole VM.
And that can actually
be pretty painful.
So perhaps users are
going to get upset
because it's going to
take them long time now
to launch these private
browsing sessions.
And the other problems to is
this solution actually has
bad usability.
And the reason I say that
is because now it's actually
difficult for users to
do things like take files
that they've saved in
private browsing mode
and then take them to the
rest of their computer--
any bookmarks that they generate
during private browsing mode
that who they actually
do want to persist
will be difficult to
get those at the end.
It can be done.
But there's a lot
of friction here.
So that's the bummer.
So another thing that
you might imagine doing
is something that looks
like approach number one.
But we actually implement it
inside of the OS themselves
instead of in a virtual machine.
So the basic idea
here is that you
can imagine that each
process could potentially
run in a privacy domain.
So basically, the privacy
domain access the collection
of OS global resources
that process uses.
And so the OS tracks
all that kind of stuff.
And then once the process
dies, essentially the OS
goes through and looks
at all the things
that are in that
privacy domain set.
And then purely deallocate
all those resources.
And so the advantage
of this over the VM
is that it is lighter weight
because if you think about it,
the VM is essentially agnostic
to all the OS state and all
the application state that is
actually being used to run.
So the result-- it probably
does more work than the OS
would have to do because
the OS presumably
knows all the points at which
the private browser would
be touching I/O, and talk to the
network, and stuff like that.
So maybe it even knows
things like you can actually
clear the DNS cache
selectively, for example.
So you can imagine
that it's much easier
to spin these things up--
these privacy domains--
then to tear them down.
However, the sad thing,
at least with respect
to the virtual machine
solution, is that it's harder
to get this right.
So I just described
the VM approach
as being headway
because it's essentially
agnostic to everything that's
running inside the container.
But what's nice about
that is that allows
the VM approach to only focus
on a few low-level interfaces.
And it can focus
on those things.
For example, the interface
the VM uses to write to disk,
then you can have high
confidence that it's actually
managed to contain everything.
Whereas with the
OS-- if you think
the OS is going to interpose
on individual files with system
interfaces-- perhaps individual
network interfaces and stuff
like that-- it's much
more complicated to find
all of those points at which
data can leak if you're going
to do that at the OS level.
So does that all make sense?
Why is this physics everywhere?
Ah, god, I'm being tested.
Those are basically
some approaches
we can use to provide
potentially stronger privacy
guarantees than what's
implemented in private browsers
right now.
So one question you might
have is can we still
be an anonymized user
if the browser-- sorry,
if the user is employing one of
these more powerful solutions--
if the user is
surfing through VM
or surfing one of these
privacy domains in the OS-- can
we still figure
out who they are?
And the answer is, yes.
So maybe the VM is
unique for some reason.
And so similar to how we were
able to fingerprint browsers
using that Panopticlick
website, maybe there's
something unique about the way
that the VM would be set up
that allows to fingerprint it.
And it may in fact be the case
that maybe the virtual machine
monitor or the OS itself
is unique in some ways.
That would allow a web attacker
to figure out who the user was.
And so one cute example of
this is TCP fingerprinting.
So what's the big
idea behind this.
So as it turns out,
the specification
for the TCP protocol
actually allows
some of the parameters
for the protocol
to be set by the
implementation of the protocol.
So, for example, TCP allows
implementers to choose things
like initial packet
size-- the things that
are sent out the first part
of the TCP connection--
it allows implementers to choose
things like that initial time
to live in those packets.
And so you can imagine,
and in fact, you
don't have to imagine that
this is actually the truth.
You can get off-the shelf
tools like InMap, for example,
that they actually can tell
what operating system you're
running with high probability
just by sending you packets.
They'll send these very
carefully crafted packets.
And they will look and
see things like here's
what the TTL was or here's
what the packet size
distribution was-- here's what
the TTP sequence number was.
And they basically have a
database to fingerprint.
And they say, OK, if the
return packet has this, this,
and this characteristic,
then the table
says that you're probably
running for some reason
Solaris.
You're running Mac.
You're running
Windows or whatever.
So even if we use one of
these stronger approaches
for private browsing
with a VM or an OS,
you still may be able to run
one of those TCP fingerprinting
attacks and learn a lot
about a particular user.
And one thing that's
also interesting to note
is that even if we use one of
these more powerful techniques
to try to protect the
user, the user is still
shared across both the public
and the private browsing
session.
Still uses-- visibly
using the machine.
So why is it interesting?
Well, it's interesting
because you yourself
by way that you use computers,
may leak information
about yourself.
So, for example,
as it turns out,
users have unique
keystroke timing.
So if I look at-- if I give
everyone in this class the same
thing to type in --
the quick, brown fox--
whatever that nonsense
is-- and I actually look
at the inter-key press timing,
we'll all have these unique
distributions that can
potentially be used
to fingerprint us.
Another thing that's
interesting is that users
have unique writing styles.
So there's this
branch of security
that is called stylography.
And the basic idea here is to
figure out if I am an attacker,
can I figure out
who you are just
by looking at writing
samples from you?
So imagine that
for whatever reason
you're hanging out on 4chan--
don't hang out on 4chan--
and I want to figure out if
you've actually, in fact,
been hanging out on 4chan.
So perhaps what
I can do is I can
look at a bunch of
different posts from 4chan.
Maybe I can cluster those
posts into sets of posts
that I think look
stylistically the same.
And then what I can do
is I can find things
that you've written publicly
where you're actually
attributed as the author.
I'll look at you homework
assignments or papers
that you've written
or things like that.
And I'll see do you match
any of these clusters
from these 4chan comments.
And if so, them maybe I can say
maybe send you a stern note.
Talk to the parents that
their kid has gone off
the beaten path.
Get off of 4chan.
So the reason is I would like
to look at this thing called
stylography.
It's actually quite interesting.
Does anyone have any
questions about that?
Excellent.
So we discuss how we
might be able to use
VM or modified operating systems
to provide private browsing
support.
And so you might wonder, OK,
well, then why don't browsers
require users to do
one of these things--
to have one of these tricked
out VMs or tricked out OSes?
So why do browsers
take it upon themselves
to implement all this stuff?
And so the main reason
is deployability.
So in fact, browser
vendors typically
do not want to ask their
users to do anything special
to use the browser besides
install the browser binary
itself.
This is similar
to the motivation
of the native client.
So if Google wants to
add these cool future
to end users' computers.
But it doesn't
want to force users
to install some special
version of Windows or Linux
or whatever.
So Google basically says, we'll
take care of this ourselves.
Then another reason
is actually usability.
So a lot of these
VM and OS-level
solutions in private
browsing-- as we've discussed,
they make it more
difficult for users
to persist state from
private browsing sessions
that they do actually want to
persist like downloading files
like bookmarks they create
and things like that.
So basically the browser
vendors say, well,
if we implement private
browsing modes ourselves,
we can actually allow
users to do those things.
We can allow users to
take downloaded files
from private browsing
mode and take them
to the rest of the machine.
So that seems nice at first.
But note that, of course,
that allowing users
to export some type
of private state
actually opens up a lot of
security vulnerabilities.
It makes it very difficult to
analyze security properties
that result in private browsing
modes actually provide.
And so in the paper,
they try to characterize
the different types of browser
states that can be modified
and how current private
browsing modes actually handle
the modifications at stake.
So the paper describes
this taxonomy
of browser state changes.
And so there are four
things in the taxonomy.
So one type of state
change is initiated
by the website itself.
And there's no user interaction.
And so examples of this
type of state change
think about stuff like
when a cookie gets
set-- when something
gets added to the address
history of the browser--
maybe within a browser
cache or something.
And so from this type
of state, basically,
private browsing
mode says this state
is a private browsing
mode session.
But it basically is
going to be destroyed
when that private browsing
session concludes.
And so the intuition behind
this is that because there
is no user interaction
in creating this state,
then perhaps the right
thing for the browser to do
is assume that the user
wouldn't want that to persist.
So another type of
browser state change
is initiated by the website
that the user is visiting.
But there is some type of
user interaction involved
in the state change.
So an example of this might
be the user installs client
certificate or maybe
there's a safe password.
So the user tries to
login to something.
And the browser says
very helpfully would you
like to save this password?
And then if the users
says, yes, then these types
of things, say
passwords, can actually
be used outside of the
private browsing mode.
And so it's a little
bit unclear in principle
what the policy
for this should be.
So what ends up
happening in practice
is that browsers
typically allow statements
in this category that set
in private browsing modes
to persist outside of
that private browsing mode
under the intuition that the
user did have to say yes or no.
If the user said, yes,
then maybe the user
is smart enough to
understand that they
save some password
for some unsavory site
and someone comes
on later and figures
that out, that's the users
fault-- not the browsers fault.
So it's a little unclear
what the best policy is here.
But in practice, this
type of state change
is allowed to persist outside
of private browsing mode.
So there's another type
of state change, which is
purely initiated by the user.
And so here you can think about
things like setting a bookmark
or maybe downloading files.
And so the story
for this state is
similar to the story
for the state up here.
So basically because
the user was explicitly
involved in the
creation of that state.
Private browsing modes
typically say, OK, it's
OK to persist these
types of changes
to the outside world outside
of private browsing mode.
Then there's some
sets of state which
are actually unrelated to any
particular session at all.
So this is stuff, for example,
like an update to the browser
itself-- the actual binary
that constitutes the browser.
And so the way the browser
vendors think about this state
is this state is
essentially assumed
to be part of the single,
global state that's
available to both public
and private browsing modes.
And so eventually,
if you look at it,
there's actually quite a lot
of states that will actually
potentially leak outside
of private browsing mode,
particularly if there's
user volition involved.
So it's interesting
to think about is
this the right trade-off
between security and privacy?
So what's interesting is
that-- so the paper actually
says that it's difficult to
sort of prevent a local attacker
from detecting whether
or not you've been
using private browsing mode.
And the paper was
a little bit vague
about why this
might be the case.
So one reason why
this might be the case
is because some of this
state that actually leaks
from private browsing mode
to public browsing mode,
essentially it can
actually contain
hints the state was generated
in private browsing mode.
So for example, on
Firefox and Chrome,
when you generate a bookmark
in private browsing mode,
that bookmark has a bunch
of metadata with it.
So for example, the
time that it was visited
and things like that.
So in many cases,
that metadata will
be set to zero or
some null value
if that bookmark was generated
inside of a private browsing
mode.
So then later on if someone
controls your machine,
and they look at your
bookmark information--
if they see this metadata set
to this zero and null value,
they can say, aha, that
bookmark was probably generated
in private browsing mode.
So one thing to think
about is typically
we talk about browser security.
We talk about, OK,
what can people do
with JavaScript or HTML or CSS.
One thing you might
want to think about
is, well, what can people do
with plug-ins or extensions?
So in the context
of private browsing,
plug-ins and
extensions are quite
interesting because they're
not constrained in most cases
by the same origin policy.
They can constrain
stuff like JavaScript.
And what's interesting is that
these extensions and plug-ins
typically run with
very high authority.
Loosely speaking, you can think
of them as like kernel modules.
They implement new
features directly
inside the browsers themselves.
And so that's a
little bit problematic
because these plug-ins
and extensions are often
developed by someone who is
not the actual browser vendor.
So what that means
is that someone
is trying to do something
nice and provide you
with this nice value add in this
browser plug in or extension.
But that implementor
might not fully
understand the context,
the security context,
in which that extension runs.
So that extension may not
implement private browsing mode
semantics.
Or it may try to implement
it to do it in a bad way.
And so as I'll describe in
a couple of minutes, that's
actually bad from the
security perspective
because that means if we add
some of these new plug-ins
or extensions, you
now can't strongly
reason about what the
resulting [INAUDIBLE] are.
Now, one thing that's nice
is that plug-ins are actually
probably going the
way of dinosaurs.
So as you probably know, HTML5
adds all these new features
like the audio tag
and the videos tag,
and stuff like that.
And so a lot of these new
features were designed to allow
people to get away
from plug-ins--
to get away from Java--
to get away from Flash .
So when people in the
past wanted do things
like have rich 2D
or 3D graphics,
they'd have to do something
like Java or Flash.
Now they can use
things like Web GL.
They can used things
like the canvass tag.
So probably plug-ins
are going away.
In fact, the IE
team for example,
has said that in a
couple years they
don't think anybody's going to
be using plug-ins whatsoever.
It's all going to
be HTML5 type stuff.
In fact, if you go to YouTube--
I don't know if you've noticed.
But a lot of times if
you go to the video,
the video is actually using--
it's called an HTML5 player.
They've gone away from their
standard plugin-based one.
So that's very interesting.
You can already see
sites trying to move
towards this new plug-in world.
However, extensions
are probably here
to stay for at least
the foreseeable future.
So it's still important
to get those right.
So, yeah, the last thing
that I wanted to discuss
is a paper was written in
2010-- that's four years ago.
So you might think
to yourself what's
changed about private browsing?
And so at a high level,
private browsing mode
is still tricky to get right.
And the reason why it's
tricky to get right--
a couple of reasons.
So first of all, because
the browser [INAUDIBLE]
is still growing because of
things like this HTML5 stuff.
The interface, which needs
to be secure with respect
to private browsing
mode, that frontier
is always getting bigger.
And also a lot of
times developers--
they are more focused on to
adding cool, new features.
And then the
privacy implications
get taken up later on.
And so in practice, it is
still tricky to produce
a private browsing mode which
catches all potential data
leaks.
So one example, there
was a Firefox bug fix
from January, 2014.
And the basic idea is
there is this extension--
it's called pdf.js
is basically a way
to look at PDF files using
pure HTML5 interfaces.
And so as it turns
out, this extension
was allowing public mode cookies
to leak when it was being
used in private browsing mode.
The idea is that let's
say that you visit
some websites in public mode.
You want to download some PDF.
Maybe you get some
cookie that comes back.
You come back in
private browsing mode.
You want to view another
PDF from that site.
And then pdf.js is actually
sending those public mode
cookies along with any private
mode things that were set.
And so in the lecture
notes, I actually
have a link to the
bugzilla discussion
about the particular bug.
So the fix was
actually quite simple
once they realized
this was the problem.
Basically they just
have to add a check that
says morally speaking, am
I in private browsing mode?
If so, do some things--
and one of those things
is not from the cookies.
So the fix here is
actually quite simple.
But the challenge was
that once again, people
added this cool, new extension.
But it hadn't really
crossed their mind
to do this full, invasive audit.
And say where are all
the places at which
private browsing with
semantics might be impacted
by this particular plug-in.
There's another
interesting one too
this is actually
the discussion we
had about 30 minutes ago
about what happens if you have
private tabs and public tabs
where you open at the same time
or very close to each other.
There is actually
a bug in Firefox.
I think that's from--
let's see here--
yeah, 2011, which
is still unfilled.
And the basic idea
is that if you
go to a task in private
browsing mode-- OK,
you go do some stuff.
You then close that tab.
You then open a new
public mode tab.
And you go to about:memory.
So as you probably know, a
browser is defined as fake URLs
and telling information
about how the browser works.
So you go to the private
tab, close it up,
then go to about:memory.
This is going to
tell you information
about all the objects that
Firefox has allocated.
So what would happen is that
window objects are typically
deallocated-- they are
[INAUDIBLE] in Firefox.
So what ends up happening is
that when you open up that new
public mode tab, go to
about:memory you can actually
find information still about
that private mode window such
as things like a
URL, for example,
that will tell you how much
memory to allocate and all that
kind of stuff.
And it's all in the plain text.
And so that's an example
of how these very subtle
interfaces and browsers
that can actually
leak a lot of information.
And so it's very interesting.
If you look at the
bugzilla discussion,
it's actually pretty interesting
to see how these problems get
resolved in real life.
And I put a link it
so there is a message
that this book was deprioritized
when it became clear
that the potential solution
was more involved than
originally anticipated.
So that's a pretty
long discussion
about how do we fix this.
And it involved changing the
way that garbage collection is
done.
And it's very tricky because
if you invoke it too often
then it gets performance.
So there's this long
discussion about this.
So they said, "It
was deprioritized
when it was clear the
solution was more involved
than anticipated."
And then in response,
a developer said,
"That is very sad to hear.
This could pretty much
defeat the purpose
of things like session
store for getting
about closed private windows."
So the developers
about this stuff.
Like in the case of
the session store,
this is storage
feature for HTML5--
they had gone to
a lot of trouble
to make it delete
things that belong
to these closed private windows.
But, basically, what
this bug did-- it still--
it basically still
left information
about that stuff sitting
around in memory somewhere.
So long story short,
it's still very difficult
to get private browsing right.
And in fact, there are actually
off-the-shelf forensics tools
that you can download
that will actually
look for evidence of both public
and private browsing modes.
So if you're an
attacker, you don't have
to roll your own custom tool.
There's this one
they call Magnet.
I think it's an internet
evidence finder.
You just go get this thing.
It'll do things like
look through your page
file for RAM artifacts.
And it will give
you a very nice GUI.
It'll say here are
the images I found.
Here are the URLs.
So in practice, these
private browsing modes
still do leak some information.
All right, so next section,
we'll talk about Tor.